Jordan we need to be surely qualified
you're not just a sneakerhead you are a
Nike guy so you definitively are coming
from Team Nike when even having this
conversation I am a huge sneaker head
and I do love Nikes but my expertise is
not just Nikes I know all the major
brands well talk to us why didn't it
work with Kanye and Nike to begin with
and why could it work for adidas well
actually it did work for Kanye and Nike
for a while Kanye was one of the first
people to open Nikes eyes up to really
making high high high quality shoes and
the easy line of shoes from Nike they
sell for more than five thousand dollars
who the hell is buying Yeezy vintage
Nike kicks for five grand that's crazy
town sneakerheads athletes entertainers
the shoes only came out a couple of
years ago actually just over a year ago
the Red October Yeezy came out it's
selling for five or six thousand dollars
it's really unbelievable what Kanye's
influences in the sneaker world so widen
I could leave him or he leave Nike you
know there was a difference of opinions
between what Kanye was hoping to do with
his name and the easy brand and what
Nike was hoping to do with their name
and brand and ultimately Kanye moved
over to adidas but Kanye wasn't only
with Nike for a while he made shoes with
Reebok he made shoes with babe he even
made shoes with Louis Vuitton and so now
he switched over to Adidas really he's
been with more brands than anyone I can
think of what do you think Kyle yeah I
think it's fascinating mean it's a
fascinating market it's a masterstroke
of behavioral economics so you know
scarcity is all but these things aren't
that scarce like LeBron James has a shoe
with Nike come out all the time so we're
on the 30th Air Jordan they're not right
right but Kanye's are kind of scarce
which is why you see them going for five
six thousand dollars so it's the one
part of the market that you could
conceivably justify
look what's the ultimate play I mean
obviously these this limited-edition run
isn't going to move the needle much for
adidas is the hope that there's some
sort of halo effect that other Adidas
shoes become cool because of these
Kanye's you that's exactly its marketing
so reportedly they're paying him about
ten million dollars
you do the math 350 shoes they're only
selling 10 million bucks is a fraction I
mean Kevin Durant's contract is 300
million with Nike so if they take a fire
with Kanye even if he is a colossal brat
that's nothing compared to what they
have to pay athletes yeah and they're
only selling the shoes for $350 so only
says so so is it safe to assume Jordan
this sneaker is gonna be a complete
blowout this weekend so hot Kayne
doesn't need to be on talk show selling
it it's gonna sell itself just because
it's got his name on it this shoes gonna
sell out and any shoe that Kanye wears
is gonna sell out there were a couple of
Nike shoes that Kanye wore an Air Max
one with animal print on it and an Air
Max 90 with an American flag on it they
sell for thousands and thousands of
dollars just because Kanye Wharram and
the Marcus understand you're the
ultimate sneaker head what is it about
Kanye that makes everyone want to wear
her shoes I mean Snoop Dogg doesn't have
this kind of pull no and Snoop Dogg has
a contract with adidas too but nobody
cares about his shoes Kanye it's like
anything he touches turns to gold 4th of
July a couple years ago they came out
with a red a white and a blue air max 90
Kanye was seen wearing the red one and
the red one sells for five times as much
as any of the other colors and honestly
I couldn't tell you why all right Kyle
you tell us why if this is a perfect
case in behavioral economics help me out
brother I'm broke I think it's because
he's so polarizing and because people
talk about it I mean we're all talking
about it right now this is kind of this
is the game it's all about hype so back
could come out with sneakers Beck who
won the Grammy and no one would care
Kanye who stepped up to him on the stage
and he does sell the sneakers yeah why
do you get this I mean it's fascinating
but do I really get it no and I like
sneakers I used to buy them but I mean
question about these new shoes that are
gonna come out are they gonna be bought
by flippers like other shoe flippers
we'll buy these and immediately how does
it work yeah yeah yeah
and I mean they'll be bought by sneaker
heads that will keep them or people will
buy if they can get them to buy two
shoes keep one sell the other pair
that's kind of to pay for the first pair
coming Jordan how many are you gonna buy
I'm not gonna buy him I don't think
Kanye issues I'm just not a huge Kanye
West fan and I don't collect adidas but
I will tell you one thing I think that
adidas is using the release of this shoe
to really tackle a big problem in the
sneaker world and that's how to deal
with these limited edition releases the
supply and demand is just so crazy
people are camping out overnight causing
riots breaking into malls and adidas
launched this new confirmed app so that
people could sort of RSVP for the shoes
that they want and go pick them up in
person and I admire adidas for trying to
tackle this crazy robots for tackling
this you know what that is my brother a
first-world problem we're gonna end it
there